I've been really excited
about giving this topic.
I've had it on my brain
for several months now.
And I'm glad to get out
some of this information.
I just want to praise everyone
that showed up for this.
The title that
includes Best Practices
for Administering
RStudio in Production
is not a very sexy title.
So I'm really glad that
people showed up for the talk.
I do have a lot of
topics to go through.
I'll try to go through quickly.
Give you an overview of a
number of different topics
I think are important before
jumping into the demos.
So I work in
Solutions Engineering.
And at Solutions
Engineering, our team
helps you integrate RStudio
products into your system.
So things that
involve integration
are things like authentication,
security servers,
cloud architectures, databases,
Spark, TensorFlow, Kubernetes.
All these things that
surround your our environment,
these are the things that
we get really excited about.
We have a great team.
You might have seen us surround.
The team members are Sean,
Edgar, Cole, Andre, James,
Kelly, Chris, and Alex.
And we hang out in
a variety of places.
The best place to find
us is in Community.
And we hope that
you'll go to Community
and interact with us there.
We have a GitHub page
and our own website.
And we frequently contribute to
the Support and Docs websites.
This webinar is really
designed for the R admin.
Sometimes I call it
the R admin, the data
scientist who wants to do more.
They want to do things like
pipelines and installations,
scaling in building
these platforms.
If that describes you, welcome.
You're in the right place.
There are evangelists
people who are
trying to get RStudio
and R more widely adopted
in their organizations.
IT ops, of course, always happy
to have of IT ops on board.
And anyone who
wants to try RStudio
of Professional Products.
If you don't know anything
about Professional Products
and this is your
first time here,
this is a great way to get
introduced to Professional
Products, we're going
to like actually
walk through all of them.
So RStudio empowers
individuals to be
productive with data science.
We believe in things like--
well, we're strong believers
in open source and reproducible
research.
And we believe in things like
APIs and interoperability.
We want to have our
work be really usable
with clear documentation.
We believe in inclusivity
and collective success.
We really want all
of the work that we
do to have lasting value.
So we take a long-term
approach here at RStudio.
We build open source and
professional software
for data science.
Our open source software is used
in almost every organization
that uses R. When organizations
benefit from open source
software, we think
they have an obligation
to reinvest in the
community that provided it.
Organizations can contribute
to our open source
software in part by purchasing
our professional products.
But our business does
not rely on altruism.
R professional features
include important things
that customers want like
security, authentication, load
balancing, and support
many other things.
And these are the
products that we sell,
RStudio Server Pro, RStudio
Connect and RStudio Package
Manager.
And then the money
that we make from
these professional products
funds are open source software.
Most of the money
that we earn actually
goes into open source software.
What's the relationship
between R and RStudio?
Well, we don't own R.
We don't package it.
We don't distribute it.
Our core team has 20 members.
And zero of them
are from RStudio.
We like to say RStudio
sits on top of R.
So you standardize on R first.
And then install
our products second.
We assume that you have chosen
to invest in R. In fact,
last year, I gave a webinar
called Professional R
Tooling and Integration, where
I talked about legitimacy,
competencies, and adoption.
So legitimacy is
about recognizing R
as an analytic standard.
And competencies are about
understanding and managing
R tooling.
And adoption is about relying
on integrated R-based solutions.
So today, we're going to be
talking about competencies
and where those
competencies come from.
How do you learn about R?
This is a big problem actually
with a lot of our customers.
They don't know how to
administer our products
in their organization.
And there's a couple
of reasons why.
First of all, R is relatively
unknown in most organizations.
There's no single place to get
all the information you need.
It's really hard to see
the forest for the trees.
There's a lot of
pieces involved.
A lot of things are
changing very quickly.
So we see a lot of our customers
going through a lot of trial
and error.
Some of those include
organizational hurdles.
For example, the
IT department might
be completely separate from
the data science department.
And maybe the communication
or the support isn't there.
Or there might be
resource limitations.
Like maybe there's the
funding for the headcount
is separate from the
funding for the servers
or the infrastructure.
And people aren't able to get
the servers that they need.
So today, I want to share some
best practices for managing
RStudio in production.
I want to share the
product requirements,
go over some tips, and give
you a path for getting started.
My goal is to give
you a big picture
view of what success
looks like, assuming
you're using R products.
So I want to share five best
practices for administering
RStudio in production.
Number 1, keep your
system up to date.
So you're going to want modern
tools for your data science
platform.
That means modern operating
systems and modern browsers.
You'll be using the
cutting edge tools.
You'll be doing
cutting edge analysis.
You'll be hiring people
with very important skills.
And you're going to want modern
tools for all of those things.
You'll need a C++ 11 compiler,
so that you can build the R
packages on your system.
And you'll want to think
about your internet access.
And that's because
all of your packages
are probably coming
from the internet.
If you don't have internet
access in your server
environment-- and a lot
of organizations don't--
then it's very important
that you talk to RStudio,
because all of our
products are designed
to run in an offline mode.
Number 2, support
multiple versions of R?
Why do you want to support
Well, because you want to
be able to manage upgrades.
You want to be able to test
code on a variety of R versions.
And you want to
support projects that
depend on various versions
of R. All of our products
support multiple versions of R.
We recommend that you upgrade
at least yearly and that you
use a modern version of R,
so 3.1 or greater.
And then finally,
this is very important
that we recommend that
you build R from source.
Building R from
source allows you
to install multiple
versions of R side by side.
It's not hard to do.
It follows the standard
config, make install path.
Most organizations have a
process for building software
from source already in place.
And we have instructions
for how to do that.
Number 3, organize
your R packages.
So R packages rule the nest.
Packages will drive your
R version, your Linux
dependencies, and even
your operating system.
Data scientists will
want to access their most
beloved packages.
So say you have a data scientist
who wants like the most
recent modeling package,
and they try to install it
and it fails because it
needs a new version of R.
So you want to upgrade
that version of R.
And then you find
that you're going
to need some Linux binaries.
But those Linux
binaries aren't really
supported by your
operating system.
So suddenly you're upgrading
your whole operating system
to support that package
of R. That is not
an unrealistic scenario.
That's one reason we say
keep your platform modern
and up to date.
So it turns out that managing
packages for a single user
is quite easy, like
you do on your desktop.
But managing packages for an
entire platform is really hard.
And we should
know, RStudio knows
a lot about managing packages.
So we created a package manager.
It's called the RStudio
Package Manager.
And it solves several problems.
One problem is when your
environment is disconnected
from the internet or you're
in an air gapped environment.
You need a way to get packages
into that environment.
And Package Manager
can help with that.
Another one is being able to
serve consistent environments
to docker containers.
So if your docker container
is running one environment,
it's probably not
the same environment
that you're building on,
but the Package Manager
can help standardize
those environments.
There's also security control
for package repositories.
A lot of organizations
like to curate
the packages that gets
delivered to their organization.
And then also
Package Manager helps
with sharing internal packages.
So since Package
Manager is brand new,
I thought I'd run through a
quick demo of how it works.
This is RStudio Package Manager.
And it has this nice UI.
So people who can log
in and see all the
packages that are
available to them.
And in this case,
these are my packages.
This is my description.
I can see how often my packages
are being updated here.
So in this case, these
packages were updated March 17.
179 packages were added.
And 159 packages were archived.
And you can see that alpha sim
R package here was archived
in version 0.9, because it
was upgraded to version 0.10.
Now, all the packages
in this snapshot
are indexed with this
identifier, 1 3 0 3.
If I want to see all
of the snapshots,
I can look at this
calendar function
and see the history of
when my package is updated.
So my most recent
version was March 17.
And here, I can see this is
the specific snapshot, 1303,
that indexes that
specific set of packages.
I can copy that URL.
And I can paste it into my IDE.
And that means that
all the packages
I pull from then
on in the IDE are
going to pull from a very
specific set of packages.
Then I can take that URL, the
package repository location,
and put that in my
docker container
when I spin up the container.
And it will pull the same
packages I use for my analysis.
We call this a shared
baseline, so that everyone
is going to be using
the same packages that
are pegged to this checkpoint.
In addition to
indexing the packages,
I can also organize
multiple repositories.
So here, you see I have a
repository that consists just
of validated packages
for my group.
This repository
has packages that
were contributed internally
from my organization.
And this repository has packages
that are being pulled down
from GitHub.
So what Package
Manager allows me to do
is pull down
packages from GitHub
and compile them or
build them locally,
so that I can have the
most up to date packages.
I can also see the usage stats
for my packages, which is nice.
I can see which packages
are being downloaded
and which licenses
are being used.
So Package Manager is really
valuable to organizations
who are standardizing on
R. We hope you'll give that
a consideration.
We'll be coming back and
visiting that in a little bit.
All right, so number 4,
use route privileges.
So the group in
your organization
that installs, configure,
and manages R and RStudio
will need route privileges.
So RStudio installs require
privileges in RStudio products,
also run as root.
RStudio Server Pro
runs as the root user
in order to create a new R
session on behalf of its users.
And RStudio Connect
runs as a user
in order to isolate
applications and processes.
I'll also add that system-wide
installations of R on Linux
oftentimes involve root as
well so this is very important
that the people that have the
permissions in your system
to install R are able
to do so effectively.
So that means if
that person is you,
then you need to know how
to install the products
and the software
sufficiently on that system.
And if that person
is someone else,
then you need to help
that person understand
what this process involves.
That means installing R, the
R packages, and the products.
So the root user privileges,
you may or may not have that.
But whoever does have
that needs to have
that understanding
of what it means
to support a platform on R.
OK, and the last one, 5 is
securely manage your users.
There's two types of users.
There's R programmers
and there's end users.
And the R programmers
will need access
to R, file shares,
databases, and probably
many other sensitive systems.
Our processes for R
programmers run as the user
under a local account.
So users need local
accounts on the system
to be running these
types of analysis.
End users, on the
other hand, are
people that may or may not
know R and just consume
apps and reports.
For these, the R
processes typically run
under a service account.
And if you look at
our two products,
you'll see that RStudio Server
Pro is serving R programmers
and RStudio Connect
is serving end users.
The way you configure R
programmers and end users
are probably going to be
slightly different experiences.
And those hooking up the systems
will be slightly different
as well.
So how do you hook those up?
Well, that's where
authentication comes in.
Your organization probably
has strong opinions
on how to authenticate users.
This space is only getting
more fragmented, not less.
So if you look at a lot
of on-prem solutions today
will have LDAP,
Active Directory.
And then a lot of the web
technologies, the cloud
technologies, have things
like Octa, Duo, and Auth
and Ping and Shibboleth
and many, many more.
So we want to support as
many systems as possible
to work with your
authentication system.
And we're working
hard to do that.
And then you will go ahead
and configure RStudio
with whatever
authentication system
that your organization has.
Now, if our products
don't support
your particular
authentication system,
then we recommend
using proxied auth.
And proxied auth, users
don't log in through RStudio.
They actually log through
a proxy that you set up.
And all of this
is in the guides.
The supported auth methods
for RStudio Server Pro
are PAM pretty much.
And RStudio Connect the
supported methods are typically
LDAP, Active Directory
or PAM and SAML,
which is coming up soon.
So we're working on SAML.
Finally, I want to
mention Kerberos,
which isn't an authentication.
It's access control.
But use Kerberos to
connect to databases.
And those are supported
by our drivers.
Our professional drivers
allow you to connect
to databases using ODBC.
All right, so in summary
here's my recommendations.
Number 1, keep your
operating systems
and browsers up to date.
Number 2, plan to support
multiple versions of R
by building R from source.
Number 3, organize
your R packages
for reliability and consistency.
Number 4, use root
privileges to install and run
RStudio products.
And number 5, securely manage
R programmers and end users.
So if you stay to these
five things as you architect
and execute your R platform, you
will have a lot more success.
And there's some information.
So we've written up some
information about how
to do this online as well.
If you come to
this page, you can
see you've got professional
product requirements.
And I go through all
the professional product
requirements here.
All right, so now that we
have like a path for success,
what does it look
like to get started?
So the first thing is
to get the right tools.
RStudio makes tools
that you put together.
They are many ways
to assemble R tools.
But it's going to be
up to you to decide
how to put them together.
Your configuration depends
on what data science
means to your organization.
Our goal is to make it as
easy to install and configure
all of our products.
So your solutions might
look like a data science lab
where all your data
scientists work together.
Maybe you're building
applications in a dev test prod
framework that you're trying
to orchestrate and deliver
to end users.
You could be on-premises or
on a cloud or a hybrid cloud.
You could have a single
server or multi-departmental
deployments depending on how
your large organization is.
No matter what you're
doing, I typically
recommend thinking
about a crawl,
walk, run strategy,
where you think
about what the platform is
going to look like long term.
And then you start
with crawl and walk.
I see a lot of
organizations doing that.
And I think that's
a fine strategy.
So this is what a setup
might look like for you.
RStudio might be for
your development platform
and will connect to your
projects and your home file
shares.
Your RStudio Connect will
be your publishing platform
and will connect to your
file share and your metadata.
And then your
Package Manager will
support both of these products.
And then down below here,
we have some databases,
R data sources that
you're going to hook up
with our professional drivers.
Now, the number of
servers that you use
and the size of the servers you
use varies across the board.
You can put all three
products onto the same server.
I would call that a sandbox.
And that's fine.
We do that internally.
You could put a different
product onto each server.
And this is typically
what we recommend
is separate the products
onto their own servers.
And we call that a
data science lab.
You have three servers
that are working together.
You can double that
for high availability
if you'd like to
make sure that you're
going to have a server to fail
over to if there's a problem.
And then if you want
to extend those out
on a clustered approach,
you could do that as well.
We have some guidelines
for hardware configuration
and sizing.
And you can look
at that and kind of
get started with the
size of your servers.
All right, so once you
have your hardware set up,
let's talk about recipes
for doing the installation
and configuration.
Recipes are a list
of ingredients
that make up your platform.
They help you organize
and automate your work.
And they're probably going to
be unique to your organization.
Now, most recipes
will have a structure
that will look like code for
Linux, R, and R packages.
Then there will be a small
section for your installation.
And then the rest of it will
be about your configuration.
So if you've
installed R properly,
installation will be
pretty easy to do.
The configuration can
be simple or complex.
So I went back and pulled
out some of my old recipes.
And I wanted to
show you one here.
This is actually
the recipe that I
used to build the box that this
script is actually running on.
And you can see
that most of it is
around Linux and
just getting set up,
getting the dependencies.
And then I come down
here to the section
where I show multiple versions
of R being built from source.
And then here's my packages,
all the packages that I
installed in my system library.
And then this little
section is the install.
And that's really typical.
If you installed R properly,
hopefully our installs
go really easily.
And then this last section
is the configuration.
And like I said,
your configuration
may be complex or simple.
This is a pretty
simple configuration.
I just set a few things around
the groups and the dashboard
and memory limits.
And then that's it.
So this is a really
simple recipe.
It's something that
you can run by hand.
What you really want to
do with these recipes
is go ahead and automate them.
So my colleague, Kelly
O'Brien, gave a great talk
at RStudio Conf called
Configuration, Management,
and Tools for the R Admin, where
she argued for infrastructure
as code, using things like
Ansable, Chef, Puppet,
CodeDeploy, SaltStack,
or systems like these.
And what these do is they
organize your recipes,
so that you can manage your
platform more effectively
and automatically.
So I definitely encourage you
to have those conversations
with your team on
how to set that up.
You need to be very good
at deploying R and managing
upgrades and helping
these platforms scale out.
And to do that, you might
want to buy or procure
a sandbox that allows
you to play around
with the configuration scripts.
So the sandboxes are
great places to learn.
And if you haven't
done this before,
it just typically involves
reading a lot of docs
and trying things out.
It's tax season, and playing
with system administration
reminds me a little
bit of taxes,
you just have to read a lot
of really boring and detailed
documents and try things out.
Hopefully, when you make
a mistake in your sandbox,
that will be a
lot less forgiving
than the IRS will be if you
make a mistake in your taxes.
But the general idea
is open up the docs,
get familiar with the
work, and try things out.
All right, so what
if you've never
used any of these products?
Well, that's where the
RStudio Quickstart comes in.
So RStudio Quickstart
is a virtual machine
that runs on your
desktop and includes
all of our professional
products and includes
pre-built assets for you
to explore and demonstrate
to others.
So the reason we did
this was so that people
could experience RStudio
professional products freely
and easily.
And I want to go ahead and demo
the Quickstart to you today.
This is the Quickstart page.
This is the location.
It's fairly easy to find.
You enter your name and email.
And the download will take
about 20 minutes to download.
It's a fairly large payload.
If your internet connection
is faster, maybe 10 minutes.
And then you'll need to
also download and install
virtual box.
And virtual box allows you to
run this VM on your Windows
or your Mac desktops.
There's instructions for both.
You just pull up the appliance
and hit the Go button,
and you will be good to go.
Once that's ready to go,
you'll point your browser
to local host 5000.
And it will look
something like this.
Well, it won't look
like that at all.
It will look like this.
There you go.
So this is our Welcome page.
And we can take a tour.
And you can find out all
about RStudio Connect
and play around with that and
a little bit about RStudio
Server Pro as well.
So let's go ahead
and get started.
We'll just log into
RStudio Connect.
This is the main UI
for RStudio Connect.
And you can see there's some
assets here that I've already
put in to the tool.
And I'm going to go ahead and
show you a couple of those.
This is the Enterprise
Ready Dashboards.
The great thing
about this dashboard
is that it runs on Shiny
on RStudio Connect.
And it connects to a database
that we actually installed
inside of the virtual machine.
And this is done with D3.
I can click this
and we'll zoom in.
If I drill down, it
will open up a new tab.
And drill down again,
open up another new tab.
And I can decide who gets
to see this dashboard.
So for example, right
now, anyone can see it.
But if I just want to
limit it to specific users,
I could do that as well.
I can also decide
how many resources
to give the dashboard.
Now, this isn't a VM.
So the resources are
going to be limited.
But if this were on
a server, I could
increase the number
of connections
and serve more users.
So this is a Shiny application.
And Shiny applications
are really
great for interactive analysis.
Sometimes you need to
run things in batch mode
and send snapshots of the
work that you're doing.
And for that type
of work, you want
to use an R Markdown document.
So here is another dashboard.
But it's written in R Markdown.
So it might look like
a Shiny application.
But it's actually not.
It's actually a
static dashboard.
It just has a lot of interactive
graphics inside of it.
And what's cool
about this one is
that I can actually make
changes to this dashboard
through parameters that
I've added to my document.
So R Markdown can
be parametrized.
So here, if I
select new settings
and I do a new window, run
up the acceptance rate,
I can run this report.
And this will update that
report with those settings.
When I'm done with that, I
can go ahead and send out
the email.
So I'll go ahead
and run this report.
While it's running,
I'll come over here
and look at the email.
This email is also inside
of the virtual machine.
And you can see it has a star
because I just sent it today,
just now.
And this is what the
email looks like.
It's got some graphics in it.
It's got some information.
It tells me like let me know
if you have any questions.
And I've attached my
Excel document here,
which allows me to pull up
Excel and look at the data.
These are the data
in this report.
So this is a great way to
share your information.
And if you want to
distribute your information,
you can do that as
well on a schedule.
I'll hit the Schedule.
I can go ahead and set
the schedule and say,
I want to run this report every
Monday, Tuesday, Wednesday.
Save that.
And I can send myself
an email when I'm done.
I can send it to collaborators.
I can decide who else
I want to send it to.
And that means I can send
one report to one group
and another version
of this report
to another group on a schedule.
I don't have to worry about it.
And if I do any
issues, those are all
going to be tracked
in the logs here.
And I can see the logs.
Go back to my code.
I can fix the code and
publish that information here.
So how do I publish
information back in here.
Let's take a quick look.
I'm back to the welcome page.
And notice I have a lot
of other products in here.
I've got RStudio Server
Pro in here as well.
I'll go ahead and click that.
And this will deliver an
instance of RStudio Pro to me.
And I have a simple
Shiny application here.
I can run this
application in my IDE.
And you can see that I
can play around with this.
And I can publish this
to RStudio Connect.
Oh, it doesn't like it.
Let me go ahead and
create a new one.
File, New File, Shiny
web app, New app.
I'll run that.
I'll publish this
to RStudio Connect.
And while it's publishing,
what it does is it goes back
and it kind of describes
all the environment
and then sends that information
over to RStudio Connect so it
can rebuild the
environment along with all
the code and data assets.
And there we have it
in RStudio Connect.
And again, I can decide who
I want to share this with.
I can even open this
in its own window.
And then that URL will
work with anyone that's
on my machine, which is me.
I'm the only one on my machine.
But this is how you would
share a Shiny application
on a server.
Now, in addition to the Shiny
applications and R Markdown
documents that you can publish,
you can also publish APIs.
And APIs are basically systems
for allowing one computer
to talk to another computer.
And in this case this is
a plumber API and that
means that it uses REST.
And that means I can call my
API through a REST based call
like through a browser.
So I will show you
what this looks like.
If I go ahead and
try out this API,
and I say give me the
stock ticker for Facebook,
it gives me all the
information for Facebook.
And it gives me this URL that
I can use to query the API.
So there's Facebook.
I can do Microsoft.
API, pull up Microsoft.
Now, APIs are extremely helpful
for the handoff problem.
If you need to hand your R
analysis to someone else,
then APIs are a great way
to do that, because all you
have to specify to the other
group or the other system
is the API itself.
You don't have to
say anything about R.
So you can keep are
running on RStudio Connect
and use that to serve
information to other systems.
It's really nice.
They're easy to code.
They're easy to deploy.
OK, great, so let's come back
to our presentation here.
So in summary-- oh,
wait, wait, hold on.
I think I went too fast.
I want to show a few more things
on the RStudio Quickstart.
So in addition to RStudio
Server Pro, RStudio Connect,
we also have the
Package Manager,
which I've shown you already.
And you can see how this
has a curated package list.
You can also come in
here and take a look
at the Resource Guide,
which will give you
an overview of getting
started and learning
about our products.
There's this great
article here under Tips
for planning your
evaluation that
talks about how to explore
the value of the products,
proving the process works,
and testing the configuration.
So these are all great
for getting started.
If you have any questions
or need any help,
you can get that here at
the RStudio Community Forums
under the Help section.
So that's going
to be this group.
And our team is all over this.
The person that put most of
this together was Cole Arndt.
This is Cole here.
And he would love
to hear from you.
Would definitely love to
make the products better.
So if you end up
using Quickstart
and you find that you have an
issue, please reach out to him.
Some of our most
common issues are
collected in this
Frequently Asked
Questions section on our site.
Most of the problems so far
have been around Virtual Box
more than around the Quickstart.
So this will be useful.
And then if you want to get
more technical information,
you can come here to the
official documentation.
So we hope that you'll
use the Quickstart.
Try it out.
Get a feel for it.
It actually comes in
handy for many things
that I do personally.
So I find I get a lot
of benefit out of this.
We hope that you'll get a chance
to try it out and experience
some of our products.
And we hope that it's an easy
and good experience for you.
All right, so in
summary, we've talked
about the happy path of
keeping your operating system
and browser up to
date, supporting
multiple versions of R by
building R from source,
making sure that you have
easy access to R packages,
installing products as root,
and using a supportive operating
system.
We also talked about recipes
and checklists, the crawl,
walk, run strategy, and using
a sandbox, as well as RStudio
Quickstart.
Again, reach out to us please.
Please talk to
Solutions Engineering.
We'd love to hear from you.
And then at the end here we have
a number of references for you
to go get some more
information about this.
I know this was very
reference heavy,
but I hope that it
was useful to you.
We'll be publishing
some more material like
this to help your teams scale
out their products, not just
RStudio Server Pro or
RStudio Connect alone,
but all of the
products together.
I think we'll be providing more
resources around that approach.
And again, if you
do have any issues,
please look us up on Community
and share your feedback
with us.
We'd love to hear from you.
What is the best way
to dig into the R
files that have been hosted on
the RStudio Quickstart Connect?
Yeah, so there are a number
of files on the Quickstart.
So that's actually an
interesting question.
The easiest way for
you to get the R files
is to come in to this view
and click on Source Versions
and click this and then
download the bundle.
This bundle will contain a
description of the environment
as well as all the code that's
required to make this run.
You showed how to deploy API
and Shiny apps based on R.
How does it work when
several customers call
the service at the same time?
Do add pods?
You manage to have them call in?
I want to make sure I
understand your question.
So when you deploy a
Shiny app or an API,
RStudio Server Pro is
going to create a bundle
and ship that over
to RStudio Connect.
So RStudio Connect can
handle multiple bundles
simultaneously.
So it can handle all these
bundles coming into it.
And then when it rebuilds
that application,
it's going to create a container
inside of RStudio Connect
to run that application.
So every bundle is going to
get a different container.
And that's what you
can kind of see here
with the source versions.
Let me pull up the other one.
Where's the documents?
If I come here, you can
see different versions
of this bundle being pulled up.
So this is one version.
That's another version.
And if you have multiple
assets, then I'll
have multiple histories.
Can this setup be
done in AWS as well?
I'm not sure what that
means by this setup.
But all of our tools can be
built on-prem or in the cloud.
And this exact setup that
you're looking at Quickstart
would be done as AWS.
How does storage work
between local and Kubernetes?
So we're going to do another
webinar about deployments
and how to help
deployments work at RStudio
and what the best strategies
are for doing deployments.
Right now your deployments
are being handled kind
of on the back end for you.
You know, you're not
seeing a lot of that work
like when you push a button
and you deploy an application
or when you start up a
container and it just
automatically runs for, you not
seeing the deployment process.
But what's happening there
is the same thing every time.
You create an environment.
You describe the environment
that you're developing.
You bundle up the code.
You ship it over.
And then you reconstitute that
environment in a new location.
That's just how
deployments work.
So those three
processes are going
to carry over every time
you're creating a container.
So the question is, how
does day storage work?
Well, you can like
try to ship over
that information through
environment variables
or something like that.
Or you can reattach that
information through shared file
storages, so shared
file storage.
Can RStudio Server Pro
run Docker R instances?
So RStudio Server Pro today
does not run Docker R instances.
That's the short answer.
In the future, we'll
have the ability
to launch jobs using
different container systems.
Let's see, and again, I
would encourage you go back
to the blog, that
was a blog post that
was written last week
that will give you
more information
about how that works.
Does the Plumber API
need end users to have R?
Yeah, so, no.
No, so the end users
on a Plumber API
are just making a web
call, just like you're
calling out to a web page.
That's the beauty of the APIs
that the R process is actually
hosted on the RStudio Connect.
So say you have a
scoring equation
that you want to run
against like a database,
your database could actually
be configured to call out
to RStudio Connect, send it
the information that needs
to score that model, and
R would run on a connect
and deliver the score based on
whatever complex analytic model
that you've created
in R and then send it
back to that system
without that system ever
having to use R. That's
the beauty of the APIs.
What's the best practice to
deploy RStudio Connect from dev
to prod environment?
Yeah, that's another really,
really good question.
And I didn't get a chance
to address it here.
But there are ways to setup--
well, first of all,
I would say generally
that your dev environment
is your RStudio IDE.
And so you're wondering
like how do you deploy it
to a production system?
There's the push button
model that I showed you.
But there's also these
programmatic deployment
functions that allow you to
publish your work on systems
that don't have any
information about R.
And that's useful for
publishing from GitHub,
for example, or from some
other automated system
that your organization uses.
Those are all really good.
And there's information
about that on Solutions.
So if I come back
here to Solutions,
and you look at Deployments, you
can find out more information
about deployments here.
Where Linux systems have shared
home directories for users,
what are the best picks for
running multiple RStudio Pro
servers?
So that's exactly right.
You're going to want
to mount your shared
NFS across all of your servers.
And there's two locations.
I showed it briefly, but
I'll go into more depth.
One is for your project files.
You'll want to put
all your product
files on the NFS server.
And the other one is
for your home directory,
which has some configuration
knobs inside of it for RStudio
Server Pro.
Both of those should be mounted
across all of your servers.
You can think of your RStudio
servers as compute engines
mostly.
They ingest
information into RAM.
They operate on it.
And they spit things back.
They don't contain
data long term.
And that goes with
Connect as well.
Connect is more of
a compute engine.
All of your content should
be on a shared file system.
All of your metadata should
be stored somewhere else.
So it's not on
those compute nodes.
I hope that made sense.
Let's see, what else do we have?
Are you able to install an
older version of packages?
I think that's a Package
Manager question.
And, yes, you can
organize those packages
any way that you would like.
Can you explain
air-gapped environments
for Package Manager?
So Emilio, I take it that you
haven't had to deal with that,
because if you did, that
would be a painful question.
Air-gapped environments are
setup for security purposes.
And those servers don't have
any connection to the internet
at all.
So the only way you can
get information into those
is through another process, like
some sort of file copy process
that the admins control.
So an air-gapped
environment means
that if you want to get
the latest information,
you can't download it.
You have to go talk
to somebody else
to have it transferred
over into your setup.
If you ever had a old
Macintosh circa 1985,
that would be an
air-gapped environment.
Could you comment on why
building R from source
is better than say installing it
from Debian or Ubuntu packages?
Yeah, so building R
from source is better
because it builds
against your own system.
So you're going to
be confident that it
will run with your system.
So when you compile, it's using
the libraries on your system.
It also, like I said, allows
you to put R side by side
with other installations of R.
So it becomes extremely useful.
But I think best
practices in general
involve compiling that
software on your system.
What we tend to use
a repositories for
is identifying the dependencies.
So when you build R, you
have to go out and find
all the things that
are needed to build R.
And that can be useful.
The repositories can be
very, very useful for that.
But actually getting the
binaries from the repositories,
I try to steer clear from that.
All right, so any
other things here?
System-wide libraries versus
user installed-- yeah,
so, Matt, that
information is coming.
Like there's a lot
of work that we're
doing right now when it comes
to a library and package library
management, making
things reproducible.
So your question is
a really good one.
How do you handle libraries,
system-wide libraries
versus user-installed libraries?
Traditionally, the sys admin has
control of your system library.
And then your users have
control of your user libraries.
And that tends to be
what we recommend today.
That's kind of the
de facto standard.
I think in the future, we'll
have better organization
around libraries and how
they interact with projects
so that things become
more reproducible.